[Music]
i'm always on the lookout for tips
tricks life hacks so we've curated some
of our favorites
just for you in a segment we're calling
hot tips
watch this one of our favorite shirts
shrunk in the dryer
so we decided rather than keeping it in
the drawer we would turn it into instant
wall art
it's really simple all you have to do is
cut wrap and staple
be sure to follow these tips it's great
because you can use old concert shirts
or kids shirts
favorite fabric tote bags or even
sweaters
free wall art and a keepsake this is a
great hack for all those t-shirts that
you just can't part with
[Music]
as g ramsay would say schultz
i'll show you how to cut pregnant
challenge meaning that there's two bulbs
in here this is where the baby is is the
mom
sounds horrible but you want to cut
through them both the two shallots
peel them they separate them when
there's one shallots
four pieces strips while keeping the
root intact
horizontals and then you dice
same as an onion you do the little
flippy cut flip it back
cut cut cut and that's how much waste
you should have
these pumpkin seeds i do not rinse them
because i want them to have the
pumpkin flavor the purple pumpkin
you can sheet pan it probably like what
two three fifty like for 10 15
20. takes longer than you think on a
sheet
um i'm using the miyoko's it's a
non-dairy
butter just put like a tablespoon
of this butter but if things start to
get a little dry you can always add like
the tiniest amount like
just little slivers on top it's all
about by the way this is a big one too
big lowry seasoning salt right on there
yeah baby nuts are such a good
source of protein hey drew it's darcy
and i have a hot tip for decorating at
home for halloween this year
did you know you didn't have to leave
your house to trick or treat
just put candy in all the rooms one fun
idea
is candy in small bowls and then
to make it a little more personal you
can have
each bowl have a different theme you can
have
pumpkins and scarecrows and bats
and witches here you can cut out the
artwork
or of course draw your own fun for the
kids and
you can take art to toothpicks or you
can just stick it in
you can blow it up put it on windows
just have fun with it
and voila this witch
has eaten too many candy corns it's a
fun easy idea
and most of all just have a good time
you can make the cutest fall pumpkins
this year
and all you need to do is steal your
kids pool noodles before the summer is
over so go grab those noodles and then
just start cutting them up
and then take some fabric or a scarf cut
it into a small piece
and tuck it into the end of the pool
noodle to make stems i use
jenga pieces from a dollar tree version
of jenga
i stuck them in the end of the pool
noodle and then tied some raffia or
ribbon around them for a cute little
detail
you can make so many of these pumpkins
and they're super fun here's a little
diy hack for those of us who don't want
to pay
20 to 120 for a leather plant hanger
head to your local goodwill and go
straight to the belt section
and grab two belts that are roughly the
same length i lucked out and found these
two that were
the exact same style so then lay the
belts down in a crisscross
and place your plant on top now all you
have to do is close the belt loops on
the last
notch and you're done hey drew this is
joe and i'm gonna go ahead and show you
two of my favorite workout tips now my
first workout tip we're going to be
holding an elbow plank
with a hop step now when you're in your
elbow plank
i want you to squeeze your glutes and
really engage that core
now the hop step we'll hop our feet out
and hop our feet in what the tip is
is that if you'd like to modify that hop
step you'll just simply walk your feet
out out and in we'll go for those
repetitions okay
if you really want it to burn just hop
out pop it
hey drew it's erin and we are going to
talk about
slugging here's the big trend going
around tik tok right now
what you do is you take a little bit of
vaseline rub it in your hands and you
smear it
all over your face you don't want to put
a whole bunch on just a little bit
and you smear it all over and it seals
in all the moisture because
vaseline isn't occlusive meaning that it
won't let moisture
out if you have oily or acne prone skin
maybe stay away
so this is what i've been doing lately
and loving it after i put on all my
nighttime skincare i take a little bit
of vaseline
and i pat it on my under eye on my laugh
lines
and right on my forehead where i'm
starting to get these lines so what do
you think drew would you try slugging
i can't wait to incorporate that tip
into my routine
beautiful and brilliant